imagine for a moment that you've never
heard of a board wipe before no wrath of
God no Blasphemous act no toxic Deluge
and certainly no farewell alternatively
we can imagine that you have heard of
these things like You're Vaguely
Familiar with them but nobody really
plays them because why would you that's
not how Commander is played we can
imagine resulting environment of decks
that commit hard to the board with no
fear of punishment Decks that prioritize
proactive plans and pushing damage
rather than developing slower engines
and sculpting a hand players run less
ramp and likely less card draw in some
cases as well because there's less of a
need to weave that stuff into the rest
of your game plan and there's a heavier
focus on building an unbeatable Board of
synergistic nonsense so let's say that's
the universe we live in now let's say
somebody casts a wrath of God
everybody's collections of mid-range are
wiped out in one Fell Swoop backup plans
are scarce hands dwindling in size looks
of dejection resentment anger even cross
the faces of everybody else at the table
the unspoken rules have been broken the
format as it was known by these
hypothetical people thrown on its head
with a single card nobody prepared for
this because why would they this isn't
how the format is played where am I
going with this well one could argue
this is very similar to the relationship
the current EDH Community has with Mass
Land destruction just as there are ways
people mitigate board wipes now there
are all sorts of ways you could mitigate
the impact of a mass land destruction
spell like Armageddon you could play
more indestructible lands you could
diversify your ramp package with
creature and artifact based ramp you
could place a heavier emphasis on land
recursion or run second Sunrise effects
you could run more extra land play
effects and be careful to keep some
lands in hand at all times and you could
run lower curved Decks that require less
Mana to do effective plays Mass Land
destruction is acutely painful largely
because people don't prepare for it and
people don't prepare for it because it's
not commonly accepted as a major part of
the format it's worth keeping in mind
that frequent board wipes being accepted
as a fact of life at most EDH tables
isn't some natural fact that got plucked
out of the ground wholly formed and the
fact that Mass Land destruction is
mostly absent from EDH tables isn't a
natural fact either the reason why
people are frequently prepared for one
and frequently unprepared for the other
comes down to social factors now does
that mean that Armageddon and wrath of
God are equivalent cards in some
objective sense sharing a common de na
even if they're interpreted differently
by the people who play EDH the answer to
that is more complicated than it seems
and I'll touch back on the question a
little later but I'll start by exploring
the answer that most players would give
you no they're obviously not why aren't
they well lands produce Mana a
fundamental resource required for
playing the game whereas creatures are
just the guys you hit your opponents
with if creatures are wiped players can
usually keep casting spells whereas if
lands are wiped they often cannot not to
bring a key piece of vocabulary into
this Mass Land destruction is a form of
stacks Stacks is a broad category of
card with conflicting eological claims
that I will not be getting into but the
most basic definition of stacks is that
it's resource denial a 2013 post on MTG
salvations EDH Forum lists 14 cards as
the universal colorless Stacks package
of these four remove lands four keep
lands or other permanence tapped down
three increase the cost of spells and
the other three perform other effects
that are broadly in line with the rest
of these things the common theme is that
all but one of these Target Mana in some
way and it's also common to see cards
that Target card draw among classic
Stacks pieces broadly a Stacks deck is
one that looks to restrict the table's
resources and then break parody on those
restrictions basically to do something
to everybody and then play in a way that
isn't as affected by that thing examples
include playing a winter orb with a
bunch of mattera rocks on board playing
a smoke stack with a bitter blossom on
board and playing mostly creature spells
with cards that tax non-creature spells
on board in common EDH parlons there are
a number of other cards that also fall
into the stacks descriptor cards that
prevent players from casting certain
spells cards that limit how many spells
a player can play cards that prevent
abilities in some way and even cards
that prevent players from using
graveyards these are also sometimes
called Rule cards the stacks archetype
is traditionally all about denying your
opponents the tools they need to play
the game a modern deck known as Lantern
control is the most distilled version of
this idea control opposing draws to
prevent them from finding anything
useful prevent the opponent from
attacking with a card known as ins
snaring bridge and then eventually win
with incremental Mill or another slow
but compact wincon as Sam of ristic
studies laid out in his video on the
deck the gameplay goal of the deck was
less to win than it was to prevent the
opponent from playing Magic the
Gathering to assemble a Rube Goldberg
machine that could prevent The Unlucky
opponent from taking any meaningful game
action this Amplified version of things
makes it clear why many staxi strategies
are Taboo in EDH they are all about
restricting the agency of players this
stands in contrast to the most popular
Visions for the EDH format that it's a
pallet to be drawn upon a format where
more expressive strategies have room to
breathe this vision of the format was
codified by the RC rest in piece in the
cards they choose to ban and why sway of
the stars is banned because it nullifies
all the gameplay that came before it
making those actions irrelevant Iona is
banned because it has the potential to
lock a whole player out of casting
spells if their deck is monocolored a
number of other cards are banned for
making agency denying strategies just a
bit too easy whether these bands were
deserved is outside the scope of this
video but they do indicate a pattern
player agency is important in EDH on
this much I agree it's good when all
players get to play a part in an EDH
game and it's never a great feeling when
somebody feels truly left out of a game
however over time we as players have
developed a skewed vision of what player
agency actually looks like able to
perform meaningful game actions is the
bar for player suppression when it comes
to Lantern control but when it comes to
EDH the definitions are much murkier we
can think about two different situations
in an EDH game as an example in
situation A the table is in a soft lock
from a Stacks player with a 90% chance
of losing to that player in the next few
turns in situation B the table is wildly
behind in resources compared to an ER
Dragon player and has a 90% chance of
losing in the next few turns these
situations are identical in terms of
ability to perform meaningful game
actions it's just as easy to break out
of the stacks player grip as it is to
catch back up to the ER Dragon player
yet the first one is generally thought
of as the much more objectionable one
one possible reason for this is that a
lot of players seem to think of their
deck as more of a fidget toy than an
actual game piece you have some sort of
synergy thing that your deck is meant to
do and being able to complete a few
entirely insignificant game actions on
your turn to scratch that brain itch
registers as a more positive thing than
being able to do nothing at all this
isn't some radical observation but
things get a bit uncomfortable when we
consider that large portions of
Commander decks are snowball mid-range
in some form or other decks with
abundant tools to keep getting ahead
once they're already ahead why don't
these violate conventions of player
agency shouldn't decks give opponents
more opportunities to catch back up I
mentioned excessive counts of win more
cards as a strategic Folly in past
videos but isn't this deck building
Choice a bit rude as well you can say
just play removal but that logic Works
equally well for a Stacks piece like
ward of Bones as it does for a
turbocharged engine like Camille the
inner Sun even as the former is going to
catch you a lot more side eye than the
latter as another example let's talk
about one of the most agency denying
cards that's widely played in EDH to
fairies protection being completely
disallowed from interacting with a
player in any form for a whole turn
cycle is wildly disempowering a core
feature of Magic the Gathering is that
there are different axes on which to
attack your opponent life total can be
hit non-creature permanence can be
knocked out with removal spells can be
countered and creatures can be hit with
either removal or by forcing blocks even
if somebody plays a fog or counters a
removal spell there is still usually a
counterplay that a prepared player can
execute not so with teferi's protection
for three Mana all board interaction and
forms of damaging a player are shut down
until that player's next turn with a
counter spell being the only possible
option for counterplay It's the sort of
effect whose all-encompassing nature
would be valid at an inflated Mana cost
of something like five Mana but instead
it's costed at three the same amount as
most board wipe Dodges you get
invulnerability as just a little bitty
tact on side benefit I have a similar
problem with the one ring it's a
powerful draw spell for four Mana it's
indestructible
and it makes a player invulnerable to
most forms of life loss until their next
turn in both cases these are cards with
one primary mode but also a stapled on
effect that dramatically reduces the
number of meaningful game actions
opponents can take people know these
cards are strong but I haven't seen much
complaining about these particular
Clauses being on these cards and it's
not hard to guess the reason why these
cards don't restrict the fidget toy
opponents can still putter around
inconsequentially with value permanence
even if they're about to die to a
massive turn from the tfairy protected
or one ringed player what I'm
illustrating with these examples is my
biggest issue with the way people talk
about stacks and really the term Stacks
itself in the context of EDH it does a
poor job of describing the things people
have a problem with and often excludes a
lot of other cards with very similar
play patterns looking at the stacks
primer from 10 years ago is fascinating
as a number of cards listed as Stacks or
Stacks adjacent sound weird to a modern
Commander player's brain
edicts are one instance of this and
wraths are another these may seem like
strange inclusions for a stack specific
guide given the current dominance of
these cards and the current
unacceptability of stacks as an
archetype but in the context of older
areas of commander and 60 card formats
it makes a lot of sense it's accepted as
a fact of life now that board wipes will
be lurking around every corner of a
commander game and that every deck will
have one or more of these sorts of tools
but most 60 card games feature Decks
that have none of these things
developing a power powerful board in a
60 card format is a genuinely
game-winning proposition and creatures
are useful as tools to deal damage to
opponents not just as another permanent
type that draws cards or has a cool
ability under this previous
conceptualization of the game wiping a
board full of creatures is ripping away
resources from opponents in the same way
that ripping away artifacts is or maybe
even lands these aren't identical but
the parallels are absolutely there
another card type that Echoes back to my
frustration with tfer protection is
defensive cards attacking a player is a
game action and when a lantern control
deck runs in snaring bridge that is one
of the game actions they are looking to
curtail we can even think about go Mound
was correct to call it a cousin to
Stacks as though it does have the Escape
valve of getting less effective once the
table is down to a 1V one it's still a
form of limiting player agency all of
what I just said is fun theorizing but
it doesn't paint a full picture of
stacks and what it means for the EDH
format both as a style of card and as an
archetype the subject of player agency
naturally dovetails into a strategy that
is very much adjacent to Stacks control
some of you probably raised your
eyebrows and be using Lantern control as
an example of stacks is right there in
the name well the two strategies are
deeply intertwined they both care
chiefly about the range of actions
opponents are able to take however there
are a handful of commonly cited
distinctions between the two the most
basic distinction is that sta is
predominantly permanent Focus whereas
control is typically instant and sorcery
focused this is largely true in that the
cards people associate with Stacks are
often permanent and the cards people
associate with control often aren't but
this isn't a distinction that tells us
very much about the game a more
interesting distinction I've heard is
that Stacks is proactive whereas control
is reactive this isn't exactly true
within the context of EDH but it's not
true in a very nuanced way that is
interesting to explore so explore we
shall to start with when I say Stacks is
proactive and control is reactive what I
mean is that Stacks plays its answers
before problematic spells are cast
whereas control plays its answers after
problematic spells are cast often to
counter or remove them neither of these
styles are considered proactive in the
broader landscape of magic but
positioning them as proactive versus
reactive in comparison to each other
isn't an unreasonable Distinction on the
surface level there is an undeniable
pattern here a decent portion of stacks
pieces are only effective before spells
are cast thorn of amethyst and rule of
law cannot as a point of fact prevent a
spell after it has been cast whereas a
counter spell can so this distinction
works on some level but it starts to
fall apart when we consider one of the
most popular types of stacks pce in
Commander permanence that remove
abilities there are different versions
of these in different colors but I'm
going to use the classics as our example
here no Rod which prevents artifact
ability activations and cursed totem
which prevents creature ability
activations these can be both proactive
and reactive you can play them before a
permanent enters you can play them after
a permanent enters and you can Flash
them in in response to a permanent spell
if you have a shimmer mirror in play we
can even imagine a player seeing a
problematic artifact enter play and then
casting an enlightened tutor in order to
find and play a no rod on their next
turn this stands in contrast to the ever
popular control tool of counter spells
which can only be cast in response to a
problematic spell and being entirely
useless to deal with such a card at any
other time so which is the proactive one
a better way to think about these sorts
of cards is in terms of their
relationship with resources now I made
the argument earlier that capacity to
deal damage to players is a resource and
I do believe that however it is worth
injecting a little bit of nuance into
this because there are useful
distinctions here that shouldn't be
brushed aside in a fun quippy little
statement so I'm going to separate
resources into primary resources and
secondary resources secondary resources
is what is directly required to win
games and primary resources are what is
required to get there so we can conjure
forth in our minds something that can
allow us to win games a grizzly bear
let's say how can this grizzly bear be
rendered manifest well we need to have
the card available to us to play
physically in our hand and we need to
have the Mana to cast it so those are
our two primary resources cards and Mana
with that Mana coming from either a land
or some other source with this primary
and secondary resource distinction in
mind we can reframe the proactive versus
reactive distinction with regard to to
stacks and control Stacks is proactive
because it attacks primary resources the
basic building blocks required for
playing the game whereas control is
reactive because it attacks secondary
resources the ones required for winning
this makes a lot of sense when we look
at the ability denying artifacts I
mentioned earlier that little box in the
bottom right of creatures is what
matters as a secondary resource the
fussy colon riddled stuff in the middle
of the card is by contrast more often a
primary resource or at least this is the
pattern among cards popular in EDH if an
opponent plays a villous broker of blood
a cursed totem will certainly remove a
bit of the utility of the card but a
counter spell or removal spell is going
to be a handier solution to the problem
if getting smashed in the face by an 88
isn't your idea of a good time this
framing also comfortably places
defensive cards like ghostly prison
firmly back in the realm of being a
control tool rather than a Stacks tool
which likely feels more intuitively
correct to a lot of players so this
updated version of proactive versus
reactive argument basically Works in 1v1
formats that is in Commander it's still
a bit wrong and to understand why we
need to talk about what control is
trying to do in a 1v1 format a control
deck is one that seeks to bring the game
to a point of stability where an
opponent's capacity to win is in a
managed State before closing out the
game with some sort of compact winon
deck space is split between cards to
manage opposing threats and cards that
allow the control player to gain
advantage with a smaller portion of the
deck spent on whatever wins the game
this works because the win isn't the
primary gameplay focus of the deck
getting to that point of stability is
survival is there will be games where a
control player fails to establish enough
Advantage pieces or lets their life
total dip a bit too low and under these
circumstances a loss can still occur
once the game has stabilized to some
extent but these are largely the
exception broadly survival is the name
of the game when a control deck is
facing a faster deck one reason this is
the case is that aggressive decks don't
build in a bunch of card draw and ramp
because doing such a thing would be
wasteful you only need enough resources
to reduce your opponent's life total to
zero and an additional beater or removal
spell to help push damage is usually a
better choice than a draw engine in
Commander though this is entirely
different all decks run ramp and draw
engines because there's 120 Health among
opponents rather than 20 meaning that
Scrappy load ofth ground strategies just
don't pan out that well as a result
control X and EDH can't necessarily rely
on Survival alone to win a game one way
this manifests is in more powerful win
consons usually combos at higher Powers
but another is that targeting resources
is essential for a control deck an EDH
it's near impossible to fully stabilize
if a bunch of faster decks are able to
keep their value engines and Powerful
Mana enhancers can likewise pose a
problem being a control deck in EDH
pretty much always means hating out
opposing sources of cards and Mana
that's just how the game is played all
of this to say control and stacks in EDH
exist in a much more Tangled and messy
relationship than they do in 60 card
formats bleeding into one another with
their roles and mostly differentiable
through superficial differences and
culturally understood indicators you
could say that control targets Mana less
frequently than stacks and that is true
but doing so isn't even solely the
domain of these suppressive decks as I
mentioned earlier board wipes are
commonplace in EDH and these frequently
destroy Mana in some form or other
things that wipe creatures also remove
manad dorks things that wipe artifacts
destroy Mana rocks and things that
destroy enchantments destroy land
enchantments is this just an unfortunate
side effect are players shedding a tear
every time they incidentally demolish
some opposing Mana production stop and
genuinely ask yourself how many players
would run Vandal blast if it didn't
destroy cards with Mana abilities I'm
willing to bet the answer is a whole lot
less than 16% of all EDH decks with red
in them we all have the blood of a
thousand slaughtered primary resource
generators on our hands whether we
happen to be a Stacks player a control
player or any other sort of player you
might be thinking well that's just the
cost of playing ramp but it's not
ramping growth is the same rate as most
Mana rocks and it doesn't get destroyed
by artifact wipes green ramp spells are
basically identical to all widely
available Mana rocks in terms of
efficiency and yet they are exempt from
this Divine Mana ramp syntax Decks that
aren't green need to live in fear of
wipes eating their Mana whereas green
players don't unless they make the
voluntary choice to run dorks which are
often better costed another type of card
often considered Stacks is rules cards
basically cards that tell opponents what
they can and cannot do examples of this
would be norrod and cursed totem that
fully shut off certain modes of play as
well as cards like rule of law and even
mind sensor which dramatically restrict
the effectiveness of certain play
patterns these tend to be somewhat
unpopular since players don't like being
told what they can't do but the awkward
thing is that there are other equally
severe forms of hate in EDH that players
have simply accepted as a fact of life
when people think about non-basic hate
the number one thing they think of is
blood moon a pretty brutal hate piece
against decks with a lot of non-basic
lands even more severe is Graveyard hate
most popular graveyard hate cards Exile
entire graveyards at a time and the most
powerful graveyard hate options which
are reasonably popular cards mind you
may as well read graveyard Stone exist
this isn't to say that any of this is
unearned necessarily EDH is non-basic
glands make color fixing easier than it
should be as long as you've got the
wallet to back it up and the EDH format
also has access to some intensely
powerful utility lands likewise
graveyard strategies can be genuinely
disgusting at times so a lot of powerful
hate cards have been printed over the
years for them however I think a lot of
players would do well to reckon with the
fact that the more powerful graveyard
hate options out there are basically
Stacks pieces and even a lot of the less
potent graveyard hate out there exists
in a similar realm I'd even put a lot of
board wipes into into a similar category
particularly the ones that wipe all
nonland permanence from aboard these
sorts of cards represent an extreme
solution in a 1v1 format and are costed
with those formats in mind but this
means that when they end up in formats
with more players their effect is
outsized for the amount of Mana they
cost the fact that cyclonic Rift is in
28% of blue decks is the best indicator
of this it was an acceptable answer at
best when I played with it in standard
10 years ago but in EDH it's an absolute
Haymaker setting opponents vastly behind
in spent Mana all of this is to say that
Stacks isn't some special type of card
there are cards adjacent to the things
we call Stacks absolutely everywhere in
EDH and we accept their existence it's
only the uncommon things that warrant
the forehead scrunches the sour looks
that oh you're playing Stacks from the
table now is this a defens of stacks
necessarily well it kind of is I don't
think it should be categorized as a
wholly unique type of card as much as it
currently is but to there would be to
stop short of asking the more
interesting questions the most important
of these questions is this do stack
pieces Stacks adjacent cards and Decks
that play a lot of these things have a
positive effect on the EDH format well
the answer to that question is a
complicated one and it depends a lot on
the power level in cedh and the highest
reaches of high power casual these
things are absolutely good tools cedh
deck utilize every part of the game to
its maximum potential whether that be
disgusting graveyard Shenanigans
constant Library searching and frequent
turns with several spells cast in them
lands and manif fixing alike are also
very powerful in budget lless formats
like cedh and actually a major side
effect of doite extortionist getting
banned that I've seen cedh players
praise is that Mana hate cards
particularly blood moon have regained a
lot of their former viability now there
isn't an easy way around them via
Treasures so yes High Caliber hate in
all forms will be very useful in the
highest powers of commander and will
have a positive effect in contesting the
most powerful proactive decks however at
the more middling power levels that most
players play at these cards don't
constitute such an unambiguous good many
of the heavier Duty stack pieces
effectively end up reading Target
opponent gets to putter around doing
barely anything until they draw a
removal spot for this and is that really
positive for the game I have a couple
friends who would answer that question
with a definite yes one friend I asked
made the point that playing against an
ETB silencer like torper orb will
encourage a brago player to diversify
their deck while this isn't strictly
untrue and while it is a good thing for
players to have more diverse decks I
don't really fully buy into this the
only guaranteed fact when you play a
torper or against a brago player is that
they're going to have a really bad time
in this particular game until the card
gets removed you have no idea what
they'll do later I will always encourage
people to build resilient decks since
these are the Decks that will let
players have more fun and will be harder
to shut down but if you brutalize an
unprepared player with a Stacks piece
they almost never see the bad time
they'll have isn't undone by the fact
that they could have been more prepared
now I think a lot of players see this
fact and want to draw the opposite
conclusion that midow EDH should be an
unfettered stomp Fest and unfortunately
that's an even worse vision for the
format I made an entire video about why
I dislike that version of midow EDH and
I actually think that more of certain
types of pressure would be good for EDH
players so what's the best way of
threading the needle here before I get
to that if you're enjoying this video
consider checking out my patreon I've
been workshopping for this video for
more than 3 months and my lovely patrons
make it possible for me to put in the
effort needed to make deep Dives such as
this one all right Solutions let's start
with the subject of mass Mana hate and
board wipes as I mentioned there's a
certain in congruity to lands being an
Untouchable resource while Mana rocks
and Mana dorks get thrown in the trash
sometimes multiple times per game one
solution to the question of wipes is
incomplete board wipes I dislike
farewell more than most other cards
specifically because it's such an
absolute wipe most of the game pieces
present are just immediately put into
Exile if the farewelling player desires
it however a board wipe I do like a lot
is cataclysmic gearhulk I run it in my
Sher slide deck and it has all sorts of
great attributes there it's an artifact
for purposes of reanimation with shirom
it's a creature with an ETB for purposes
of Flicker and it has two different card
types which can allow the person who
played it ample Choice whether to keep
it around or not the deck can get it out
and Trigger it multiple times with
relative ease but it's far less
polarizing than a lot of removal engines
specifically because it allows players
to keep one permanent of each type on my
side of the board it gives me
interesting set of choices and
opportunities to break parody with it
with an especially potent card and it's
preferable for my opponents as well
despite the card being a board wipe my
opponents get a sense of agency on what
to do with their board and even when I
flicker it multiple times it still gives
some opportunity for players to develop
a board through it since they can
upgrade the cards they keep around
effectively it also punishes players who
are ahead much more than players who are
behind since a player with two artifacts
will only lose half of them whereas a
player with five artifacts will lose 80%
of them this idea of an incomplete board
wipe is also a great solution for lands
Kellin firebombers and urza CX are
examples of land hate that is less
severe than other land hate specifically
because it allows players to keep around
lands keeping even three lands is so
much less punishing than keeping around
none at all as there will be a wide
range of spells in a player's deck that
are still castable and players can
choose the specific lands they keep
rather than praying to the top deck
gauze to deliver them the correct colors
there are only two of these at the
moment as far as I know but given that
urx was printed just two years ago I can
certainly hope that Wizards of the Coast
will revisit this design Choice another
thing that it would be great to see more
of is soft hate options for interaction
that are decently powerful but less
brutal in effect there are a number of
cards that cause non-basic lands to
enter tapped and these are so satisfying
to me suddenly the players running the
fancy Mana packages are brought back to
the level of me and my friends playing
kitchen table magic in Middle School
needing to use tap lands to get more
than one color from our lands the fact
that these can threaten a double hit on
the most powerful fixing and Commander
fetchlands is especially nice I don't
get much joy out of seeing players get
Mana screwed by powerful non-basic hate
but I love to see them join the tapland
gang for graveyard hate this could look
like pinpoint exiler such as emperor of
bones or pit of offerings and it could
also look like Shuffle effects such as
endurance I want to see additional
powerful Shuffle into Library effects be
printed as a graveyard hate option it's
equally effective in the short term
without posing such a dramatic and final
punishment for the graveyard enjoyer and
also has the added utility of being able
to shuffle one's own graveyard as well
aside from soft haate a good option for
Mid power Stacks in the here and now are
some of the softer general purpose stxs
cards that already exist with the two
key ones being tax cards and rule of law
cards tax cards like thorn of amethyst
make spells more expensive most often
non-creature spells and these are nice
because they're not too hard to break PA
on and they also impact players who are
ahead and thus casting more spells much
more than they impact players who are
behind the same is true for rule of law
effects though capping the number of
spells a player can cast each turn at
one is a more dramatic effect and will
make opponents unhappy at times they can
likewise punish players who are ahead
more than players who are behind in
addition since basically all of these
are symmetrical and require a bit of
effort to break parody on they're much
more fair than a lot of other options
for Stacks my liasa deck features a
number of these sorts of softer Stacks
pieces and though I'd place the deck on
the upper end of mid power it can play
decently at both mid and high Powers
because all of the tools in the deck
disproportionately hit more powerful
decks especially combo decks my liasa
deck also features the final form of
stacks I find appropriate in mid Powers
slug effects a major critique of stacks
cards that I mentioned about 20 minutes
ago is that they limit player agency and
slug Stacks cards subvert this by
forcing players to pay with a resource
that is by fault quite plentiful in
Commander life total liasa is a
fantastic creature because her effect
punishes players who play a lot of
spells more heavily and fully prevents
combos that require casting a spell an
arbitrarily large number of times but it
accomplishes these things through the
vector of Life total this means that
stack Stacks traditionally a more
controlling strategy can take on New
Life as a Beatdown strategy forcing
opponents to make hard choices about
whether to do the plays they want to do
and face life total consequences or
whether to keep their life total at a
more safe level and hold back on their
power plays liasa and rug of smothering
are examples of cards that cause players
to lose life for each spell cast but
there are also cards that deal damage to
players for their non-basic lands cards
that deal damage to players for their
Creature Counts cards that deal damage
to players for attacking in certain ways
cards that deal damage to players for
drawing cards blood arst effects that
punish sacrifice oriented strategies and
so on I highly recommend including these
in aggressive decks as they allow for a
sort of stacks aggro blend that makes
for some really cool gameplay and puts
the pressure on opposing decision-making
without needing to flat out tell them no
EDH doesn't necessarily benefit from
people getting fully locked out or made
miserable but a format with a greater
amount of soft stacks and soft hate has
a lot of benefits it encourages more
resilient well-rounded decks it pushes
players toward thinking about their
opponents both during games and during
deck building a format where everybody
brings their Solitaire pile to play
against three other solit piles isn't a
good one and anything that pushes people
into considering what their opponents
are playing more heavily is a good thing
players should feel pressured by what
opponents are doing just not necessarily
oppressed Stacks effects that Loop in
life loss in some way are good
specifically because they pressure
opponents while maintaining player
agency more soft Stacks will also reduce
the height of the format the battle
cruiser version of EDH does appeal to a
lot of people and I do get the appeal
but there are elements of it that we'd
be well served to curtail a bit it's not
good when boards are filled up with
endless permanence that nobody wants to
keep track of when turns Take 5 to 10
minutes each where frequent board wipes
are a necessary fact of life I'm not
saying that this is a form of Ed that
needs to die off or that nobody enjoys
it but it shouldn't be the default as
much as it is currently some of what I'm
suggesting here is ways players can
change their own decks but a lot of it
comes down to Wizards of the Coast since
they control what cards are printed as
well as the commander format as a whole
now only time will tell what exactly
they have in store for EDH but there are
some promising indicators the sort of
soft hate cards I want to to see more of
are being printed magebane lizard
emperor of Bones aan interruptor sunpine
lyx and High Noon are a handful of
designs I really like from this year and
there are others like urza silx and rug
of smothering from recent past years
that are likewise good signs of things
to come the vavo deck also serves as a
notable milestone in precon design the
fact that Wizards of the Coast felt
comfortable making a group slug Deck
full of the sort of damage Stacks I
mentioned earlier is cool and makes me
curious about what's to come we've also
seen a gradual increase in STX effects
being stapled to cards with another
primary purpose such as in the case of
Boromir Warden of the tower the sax
cards of your Tabernacle winter orb
Armageddon overburden these aren't going
to be the future of the game nor should
they be hard Stacks provides a fun tool
for the power Gamers out there but EDH
isn't going to be improved by putting a
bunch of battle cruiser players through
a trial by fire of the nastiest
permanence that have ever been printed
this format will be at its most vibrant
when it can find a balance between
player agency and inter activity between
players when players can do their own
thing but where that thing might need to
take into account the actions of
opponents and might need to navigate
around some challenges here and there
and the things we might call Stacks have
a valid role to play in cultivating that
sort of format thanks for making it to
the end and thanks to architect for
supporting the channel architect
recently had a major UI update and I've
been enjoying the increased flexibility
of the visual display as well as the
extra analysis tools a link to my decks
is down in the description additional
thanks to my patrons some of whom are on
screen now if you want to join them a
link to my patreon is down in the
description earlier I uploaded some
thoughts about the announcement last
week it's not something I feel strongly
enough about to want to make a public
video just yet but if you want my
thoughts that's where you can find them
alternatively if you want some different
thoughts of mine without paying me money
I was on the magic mirror podcast with
33 elk last week and a link to that is
in the description as well all right bye
now